the beginning of summer in the US and a
cautious reopening of beaches along the
popular New Jersey Shore in New York
City Parks sunseekers are kept apart
with circles on the grass while outside
San Francisco City Hall the homeless are
spaced to abide by social distancing
guidelines all part of a new normal as
the country emerges from lockdown but
amid the slow reopening a grim milestone
the death toll from Koba 19 has now
claimed more than 100,000 American lives
a far cry from the confident statements
just a few months ago from the US
president the u.s. accounts for almost a
third of the world's Kovan 19 deaths a
damning statistic some say for the
world's richest country it says a lot
about our public health system it says a
lot about how seriously we took this at
the beginning it says a lot about what
we need to improve for the future this
is really a wake-up call and a time to
begin to realize how important public
health is by comparison covin 19 has
proven to be worse than other recent
virus outbreaks the 2003 SARS epidemic
did not claim a single life in the u.s.
in 2009 the h1n1 pandemic claimed the
lives of 12,000 469 Americans with kovat
19 no one can say for certain what the
final US death toll will be since March
citizens have had to endure weeks of
restrictions and lots of distress trying
to stay safe from the virus but a new
Columbia University study found that
imposing the lockdown even a week
earlier could have saved tens of
thousands more lives based on the
overall premise that lives could have
been saved had social distancing sure
has been in place earlier yes in theory
we waited too long to implement those
social distancing measures hindsight is
always 20/20 so of course we know that
now
at the time there was it wasn't clear
how widespread the virus was with the
vaccine still a long way from being
available it's clear the threat from
kovat 19 will linger over a summer
shaping up to be unlike any other in
living memory
Kristin salumi al-jazeera